North America is known for its various
cryptids and urban legends from the
Mothman and the flatwoods monster to
Bigfoot and the Jersey Devil almost
every state has a tale to tell but none
are as notorious and as deadly as the
trashman of Philadelphia some know him
as Danny DeVito
or as froggy the Frog kid but his real
name is Frank Reynolds the man behind
the monster the trash man is an entity
from the darkest nightmares of HP
Lovecraft himself we cannot truly
comprehend his purpose or why he does
the things he does he roams the streets
of Philadelphia in search of new
followers and trash of course but what
he does with that trash no one truly
knows does he store it somewhere does he
feed his minions maybe he's using it to
build his city trash topia or maybe just
maybe he recycles it some believe this
round
balding goblin to be a fictional
character in a TV show but those of us
who are not complete and utter idiots
know the truth the trash man is not of
this world and the avatar of Neil Arthur
tip maybe have something entirely
different
an outer God that we've never seen
before in love cross undiscovered work
the trash man cometh he discusses a
truly viable entity that wishes to end
our world to sink civilization into
trash and to destroy everything we know
the trash pocalypse trash' get in trash
Narok it goes by many names but they
will spell the same thing the end of
days upon my travels I came across a man
in Tijuana who told me the story of el
nombre de la basura the trash man or L
thrash Ito as the locals called him he
was once an ordinary man named Frank who
loved nothing more than rummaging
through trash in the hopes that one day
he would find something valuable his
golden ticket to the high life but what
he found was copies of fallout 76 and
the crimes of Grindelwald on DVD because
no one wants that [ __ ] seriously not
even the trash man but one day all of
Frank's hard work paid off he'd found it
a Starbucks loyalty card with one ready
to be redeemed free coffee
27 years of dumpster diving and Frank
had finally hit the big leagues he would
finally get that damn venti sugar-free
nonfat vanilla soy double short decaf no
foam extra hot peppermint white
chocolate mocha with light whip an extra
syrup but for free or at least he would
have if the ward wasn't such a cruel and
unfair place unfortunately for Frank he
ran into the local gang who
coincidentally only stole Starbucks
loyalty cards but Frank would rather die
than give them his golden ticket bang
bang two in the chest and Frank hit the
ground hard they took his body and threw
it into the dumpster some say that Frank
died just the way he lived a greasy
dumpster-diving rat while others say
that he died doing what he loved the
most
bathing in trash what happened that
night I'm afraid nobody truly knows
except for me obviously
deep inside of the trash versus some
kind of cosmic being quarter Frank
telling him that he was destined for
great things
he would have revenge on those who stole
his coffee he would show the entire
world what it was like to fear trash he
was to amass a cult of followers known
as the trash monkeys and when outer gods
returned they would rise up from the
sewers and the dumpsters to engulf the
world in trash that night Frank was
reborn with a mission a purpose
whatever Frank saw changed him forever
and the greasy happy-go-lucky trash man
was no longer he was now the trash King
some say that Frank could talk to rats
and others believe that those who joined
his cult were transformed into rats so
they could revel in trash forever what
Frank promised these followers I do not
know but even to this day he roams the
streets in search of new followers and
trash of course and hard-boiled eggs
Frank loved hard-boiled eggs there are
numerous police reports of a short fat
balding man rollin down the streets in
the dark of night those who claim to
have seen the trash man described eyes
that glow crimson and skins so greasy it
appeared that trash was oozing out of
his pores many who come across the trash
King never tell their story because they
are inducted into his cult the story of
the trash man is a truly sad tale but
also quite disgusting
so the next time you order your venti
sugar-free nonfat vanilla soy double
shot decaf no foam extra hot peppermint
white chocolate mocha with light weapon
extra syrup remember Frank the man who
never got his coffee I'm telling you
this story because I stumbled across
Lovecraft's hidden work and since then
the trash King has been after me I can't
see him but I can smell him wherever I
go the smell of rotten eggs and cheap
Gucci Cologne haunts me I now know too
much and it won't be long before I'm
just another trash monkey made to search
for Starbucks loyalty cards this may be
the last video that I ever make so I beg
of you heed my warning in the words of
the late great HP Lovecraft when the
trash man cometh
there will be no Sun in Philadelphia
only trash and hard-boiled eggs Frank
loved hard-boiled eggs I'm the trash man
I swing trash all over to all over the
ring and then I start eating garbage the
trash man
[Laughter]
[Music]